debate club up first ja'crispy savage
ja'crispy I'm already liking this Oh bro
I know them
[Music]
oh and they cut it off we said buzz bah
he's about for you through the buzz and
he didn't very unique I like that you
have the mystery finish there knows how
this thing ends you're still alive I
feel is this are these family members of
yours that Amelia Earhart finished right
there yeah we don't know what happened
you know uh I met them in Atlanta after
the show trust like this dress exactly
like yeah they wear this all the time
when they are I thought it was lesbians
brother far away because I member seated
they were in the distance that's fair
and then I met them after the show man
they were really really cool I was just
exhausted I wanted to engage with them a
little bit more I would say most of my
life I do catch up but I'll go mustard
now and I will actually get mustard and
put honey in it and put real honey in it
so also known as honey mustard yeah
Jesus Christ Brown yeah Brendon
welcome to 2019 like your breaking news
here good God what I like to do it's
pretty unheard of I'll take mustard I
put honey in it yes you really try it
out honey mustard anyway so a fan of
yellow mustard because as a Kido kid I'm
wearing this romper kid mustard no sugar
ketchup a lot of sugar also a little fat
for your dumb ass Wow
really gets an idea first of all you can
see how idea you just like like you
solved the world's problems cuz you
invented honey mustard just do their mom
think if it tasted I didn't put in the
work Brendan I mix honey and mustard I
don't buy them already mix like some
loser that's what I'm saying they do the
work okay I'm gonna dress like it trying
onesie [ __ ] McGillicuddy over there
where's your broom at Big Daddy huh
food dressed like you I can work it
don't work bro hey what time with SATs
are you dressed like this backwards that
matching sweaters bro because they also
are you the rock why were your merch I'm
sorry you Michael Jordan who were you
wearing dude yeah wear your own bro all
right Rock you putting your own [ __ ] you
don't catch up hazard crystally I stole
his [ __ ] eye thing from the rock and
let's say that [ __ ] right here you've
done an eyebrow lift oh whatever that is
bro well I mean do and you haven't store
from Patrick Swayze and dr. Bonnie
another no one says anything like that
bro saw Dog the Bounty Hunter at the
airport I'll tell you that ok twice now
yep CT whatever Wow ok now you know what
it's like to spend time with you Brendan
ok new idea that's the same idea over
ever again you ever seen German you just
told me invented honey money no I said
it to you what do you know what else I
like to do I like take water and I put
flavoring in there dude and a little
sugar I call it kool-aid you got a live
bro
you gonna quit wearing your own merch
and just get out of your circle dude you
and that little twink film each other up
buckle bunnies trying to slag merch on
the side
get your life together bro we're doing
our best
hey your slang [ __ ] honey mustard
[ __ ] nasty [ __ ] NASCAR buckle
bunny bro look like a [ __ ] dude who
will not retire from Spencer's brother
you look like a [ __ ] you look like
somebody who definitely to Stu's worked
at Abercrombie and Fitch
out front of the store greeting people
for 30 years I did have that job you
know ketchup was getting two before
[ __ ] Einstein McGee over here too
thought he developed honey mustard I've
seen my Paulette Dijon and this can be
kind of fancy little spicy too you know
I'm saying he thinks I'm Stein McGee he
thinks Einstein was Einstein's first
name that's the best part of this whole
thing
it's here'll Einstein you idiot you're
an idiot there's a lot of bugs and
ketchup if you look up the stats how
many how many dead bugs are in ketchup
every bottle of ketchup it's like 30
insects in the factories all these bugs
getting this stuff it's just it's fat
what factories do you know they can't
hop it's just flies in [ __ ] they can't
prevent it they get into the mix no they
can definitely I promise you they can
prevent it look at Derek's looking it up
so he'll probably go this is Food and
Drug Administration quite little tomato
worms flies beetle spiders and rat here
are just a few added ingredients that
yangyang boy I'm in there [ __ ] that's
right son you [ __ ] how did you do a
sketch up bro huh
when would you like ketchup more than
mustard then if you got some rat in
there
I don't like ketchup because it just
doesn't it doesn't even sweet bro yeah
it doesn't even taste like tomato
anymore told you dumb red yeah it tastes
like big red depends where you get it
yeah it tastes old-fashioned get a
certain point I'm like it's just from
the past it's like we got to evolve in a
new sauce as Brahma bought that tzatziki
bruh alright honor that to Zeki
zat Zeki is how you pronounce it dude
I'm not mad a little hummus oh that's
not a sauce bro I know I was just saying
I like hummus taziki's also a yogurt
it's really a psalmist dude who I do die
hang out
an Indian on the road its wholeness his
name's dangerous Brown yeah I can't met
his little ass and you know what he's
missing a little bomb and ass I think I
think yeah I think he's gone AWOL
I think he's converted well what else we
got dude I'm with mustard most people
picked ketchup this is obviously a
percent that was all closed well dude
ketchup mmm Sinise that's the thing at a
standard cat what are you guys you guys
are doing new sauces give us an update
cat yeah hon yeah I'm not not being
racist Asians like mustard right like a
spicy mustard Chinese people do yep you
got a Chinese basically let's be honest
brother they own the big home jaundice
brothers dude okay Chinese are really
the black people of Asia is that true
be Filipino yeah I can I can see that
yeah I feel like Filipinos are the
Mexicans of Asians yeah so there's a lot
of them and they work really hard yes
yeah very family-oriented very family
ordered the smiling people they call
Filipinos a lot of times I've never met
I've never met a mean Filipino really
mm-hmm
that's a dick training it's a philomene
Oh - they call him that
really boom race it roasted call me Ben
Askren you like mustard though cat this
is like Brendan hitting on a girl this
is a [ __ ] oh this is this is my
president Theo hitting on Asian girl
yeah yeah this new thing you should try
I take honey I take the mustard do not
sign this NDA I call it honey mustard
yeah and they love it what do you do you
guys using over their cattle knee guys a
very unique sauce sriracha okay
Vietnamese hot sauce I like so much that
is yeah a lot of sugar in that too you
know that yeah
sriracha yeah you're a straight [ __ ]
dude I'll [ __ ] put I'll had a couple
of nerd ropes in my [ __ ] you little
[ __ ]
put one of those red vines up your dick
hole dude I ain't no ho son you know Sam
bro
yeah dude I'll [ __ ] put four packs of
[ __ ] uh Splenda under my tongue and
take a nap you [ __ ] yeah that's
cool bro you're aggressive with it man
boy I'll put two quarts of honey in my
[ __ ] boy you know saying go for a run
is backwards that's still a hitter bro
thank you later dude y'all afraid of a
little pocket sugar brother are you
afraid of a little sucrose big dog you
never had some pop rocks in your dick a
little bit you know nerds and you did
do I like nerds how [ __ ] you [ __ ] the
dthe up though sprees bruh do dude runts
so good holler
strawberry run so why not just make all
strawberries though cuz banana people
love the banana I like banana banana
strawberry get that lime out of my
[ __ ] family oh you like the line
sometimes when I feel like I gotta
[ __ ] change it up I'll get a lime one
but the bananas boy I like the banana
they'll like the grape ones too you guys
like the great ones great well yeah
Derek I said you guys yeah mmm my great
my brain work brought over the kill
that's too obvious man kill dude you're
right
sorry there
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]